[Music]
can life ruiner news oh it came women
just kidding I'm kidding
BM Upton no I like women submitted by
where can I request Joe Bobby and B says
no works we don't need and you have to
get a booty scan at the DMV MJ
but chief but a crack or a hole it's
kind of like the thumbprint
but then the butthole wrinkles your ass
is Mayan ambush point of that bunk bunk
I'm all wrinkles yeah how do we do mmm
motor joke I got to write all the stuff
you say today he's pretty awkward
that's what you said okay so Bart said
that he's had an itchy ass for a month
and then you're like I don't have any
wrinkles on his bunghole
that's it my ball look like calamari
just a smooth all around I thought well
you have an itchy ass is so open quick
again tell where it's fried so it's
[ __ ] red like Bridget all over well
neither spa come on use your imagination
the batter it looks like a [ __ ]
stuffed on lifesaver
that's what looks like a grilled squid
next time girls Chris that's what it
looks like a man is suing the dating app
Grindr after eleven hundred strangers
turn up at his home and job demanding
sex
oh [ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up you're not that
desirable go home take a nap you know
maybe there was a glitch in the app and
that does something that's a lot like
1100 yeah and they all showed up
throughout the throughout throughout
time right yes
throughout uh five months all Mike that
that would annoy me every [ __ ] day
like after a while just be like alright
come on in were [ __ ] but I just can't
take it anymore
as many as sixteen strangers would show
up every day how come you didn't take
his app off a Briner then is okay so
here's the story a lovely lady
haha you got pranked I say it in my head
but oh we are so so he got pranked okay
so this story's about Matthew he's 32
years old from New York what a horny
bastard so he says that his ex who he
met and dated from Grindr becasue known
as a teen has been impersonating Matthew
on the app since October 2006 I've
[ __ ] oh oh so he's created many fake
profiles using his photos and personal
details and even fake details about him
like saying that he's HIV positive
well the people are still showing up to
her work with other HIV years coming
[ __ ] to him yeah Grindr is a gay app
right it's like gay guy hanging out and
then dude a sucking 77 times I need for
gay and bisexual men yeah I just thought
it was a dating app - [ __ ] I thought it
was a dating app to [ __ ] but for the
whole of it right there like that
because about Grindr was for the guys
and gay girls they gave her home with
six years of the third at the gaze of
the boy in the lady kind yeah and in
tenders for the straight yes yes and in
blender is for everybody
inclusive in our blender I made that one
so the ex was telling the possible
suitors to not be dissuaded if Matthew
did not want any sense so that was part
of his agreed-upon rape fantasy or holy
[ __ ] that's not done [ __ ] evil I
don't know what that's gonna look like
but you know how people when they say
rape usually automatically you think an
aggressive piece of [ __ ] guys that
attacks a woman what happens when a
bluff guy picks over a guy that must be
it's like you I think you and for it
well like good well how are you gonna
stop that like no sir no no well
beaver if Justin Bieber rape Dwayne
Johnson it's probably gonna be the other
way around
no but like but I what if I love Justin
Bieber what if what is what Justin
Bieber came over I'm not taking no for
an answer
yeah I'm pretty sure Dwayne Johnson
would just snap his head in half yeah by
blowing any stage you know what if my
ex-girlfriend kept sending me girls for
five months 16 times a day I'd be like
damn you [ __ ] crazy-ass [ __ ]
pranking me well they're already at my
doorstep joke no but okay let's paint
this scenario to be closer to his so
let's say you are so she told these
girls that you like to roleplay and
fantasy rape yeah that's well c'mon
they're coming at you was like strap on
this dildos wanting to rape you because
you're into that into your but I don't
want that but if they're sucking me at
the same time might be hard to resist
something new and also it's like sixteen
drugs coming at your age that don't roll
no more than it is $16 sixteen guys no
oh
and none of these girls you want to have
sex with I know but after the 16th time
someone asked me to do sex I'm weak not
only not give in really fast attacking
you so I always wanted to practice
karate now I could do it for free it's
gonna [ __ ] up all these horny [ __ ]
and I don't know you know it's really
hard because it's difficult for me to
put myself in his shoes because I'm just
a scoundrel but what if there are 16
dudes now the history was it's dudes
right yeah but he's gay
that's how you get girls he likes dudes
oh I thought his girlfriend
put him on Grindr no his boyfriend put
in my belly
Saperstein really [ __ ] ugly girls
that are really stinky and really
[ __ ] weird and stuff like that
sixteen bus drivers Oh
is dude again oh my my the fifth month
oh I have to cut the problem by the
fifth month I might [ __ ] one just one
just one but that's a lot a lot these
are very easy a very attractive Asti
yeah I think is because oh yeah anything
in the sometimes he's very good-looking
yeah oh they wanted to ride on his hairy
chest like their ball is a snail going
going down a bush
[Laughter]
yeah so Matthew was saying in one
occasion when there was someone that was
able to break into his home oh and he
attacked his roomie were you at every
thought it was him
no like so the roommate asked that
person the intruder to me [ __ ] you
are that person attacked the roommate
I'm getting my dick whether you like it
or not oh my god I don't know it's like
there's like he's really aggressive
people are talking rape men yeah so then
that's why Matthew is suing grinder
because he's saying that after 50
complaints about the fake account
grinder hasn't done anything about it
yeah a lot of complaints you know it's
hard probably for grinder to keep
catching this guy if he keeps making new
accounts and using his pictures I would
just tell her I can't ban my name from
everything yeah so the thing with that
with the photos
wave physic processes known as image
caching or visual search that can detect
like near duplicate images and banned
them from that but greg was not even
taking stuff like that i Kenny also sue
be the boy toy to exploit one share or
identity theft yeah I think I'm not sure
where he's going with that that's [ __ ]
up but I always want to go in the money
that though yeah yeah yeah yeah that
[ __ ] you the lawyer was the one that
brought that up
I'm glad that's so shady like what if he
actually got raped I know he would have
a bigger case if he did though yeah
is he traumatized from this no so he's
saying that his entire life has been
stolen from him his privacy has been
taken from him that he's humiliated
daily and I was just a living hell so
that's why I like he says he so he
completely removed himself from social
media so he posted this but now he's
back on it so we're talking about him
you know he posted this you won't know
it where is he from New York due to
circumstances out of my control
I'm sorry stress offenses due to
circumstances out of control out of my
control I have to remove myself from all
social media I've been having issues
with a stalker who has tried and is
ruining my who's running my name through
the mud he has now created fake accounts
on gay app such as Grindr and scruff
declaring me a racist bigot and a Donald
Trump supporter it has now gone to the
media I will say that I am an avid
supporter of the LGBTQ community and
minorities alike but this defamation of
character has gone to the extreme to my
family friends fans and supporters his
sentence - hard to have this kind of
live spread about me please know I would
never do such horrible actions I love
you all if you see any post comments or
profiles no it's not me that's psychotic
so apparently the ex was contacted for
statement and the only thing that the ex
said was that it was not him who created
these profiles but he did not want to
further comments that could a [ __ ] man
who a fine July angel tonight pictures
16 school bus drivers coming over every
day that's the last time in a uniform of
not sexy hey guys thanks for watching
that last episode if you haven't already
make sure to hit that subscribe button
because we upload videos every single do
for you guys now to watch more videos
check them out of here
[Music]